results from the non-scientific poll at
david pakman.com i'm going to give you
poll results that answer the question is
donald trump untouchable no matter what
he does now before you start emailing me
saying david this is a fake poll it's
not scientific
whatever this is not a scientific poll
this is a poll reflective only of the
portion of our audience the chose to go
to david pakman.com and vote meaning
there is self-selection bias there is a
sample that is not representative of the
entire country it's just what our
audience thinks let's put up the results
pad is Donald Trump untouchable no
matter what he does seventy percent of
our audience who chose to participate
says no Donald Trump's misdeeds will
catch up with him 16 percent of our
audience believes that Donald Trump is
mostly untouchable unless he personally
murder someone a reference to shooting
people on Fifth Avenue seven percent of
our audience believes that Donald Trump
is indeed totally untouchable no matter
what he does and 7 percent of our
audience sort of isn't sure I tend to be
in the Trump is mostly untouchable camp
not necessarily with the only exception
being if he murder someone but I think
Trump has already gotten away with so
much that he will not all currently face
consequences for that I lean towards
Trump being by and large untouchable
with the exception of some something a
really major
he's also been underestimated so many
times people say he wouldn't run and
then he ran and then he wouldn't win the
primaries he won the primaries right
would it be president when he was
president hard to deny that and now
we're saying he's not going to build the
wall and make Mexico pay for it and blah
blah blah blah blah but maybe he will
maybe he will although most people
actually I saw a poll an actual
scientific poll unlike the ones on our
website only 36% of Americans have
seemed to want the wall built acquire
Gallup another point on this too I think
you know everything sticks to him for
the 65% of Americans who don't really
like the job that he's doing there
enough nothing sticks to him to the 35%
of approved yeah the very very good
point new poll at david pakman.com
results next week what is your opinion
of Megyn Kelly's decision to interview
conspiracy theorists Alex Jones on her
you network TV show that's the current
poll at david pakman.com vote and we
will have results next week